my name is Rebecca Joe let's I'm 19
years old and I intend to revolutionize
the satellite development industry I met
with dr. Yvonne Pendleton why when I was
in fourth grade and I just pulled her up
front I want to become an astrophysicist
and over time we talked to each other we
said emailed each other and she said
take the hardest math and science
courses you can I'm really excited to be
finished with UC Berkeley and that it's
given me this opportunity to change the
world with my knowledge and with my
connections my company intends to do pre
qualification of small satellites in
space there's challenges because my
gender challenges because of my age I
have learned to just be very careful
about how to approach challenges how to
fight it how to maybe avoid it but
always going forward whenever somebody
says you can't possibly do this that's
somebody daring me to do it